one good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Thursday and
it's a great Thursday because an
unexpected back to back Jackson Claude
in the studio together Ben was supposed
to be here today but he's quote so busy
so Jax is here even better even better
I'm filling in for Ben who's filling in
for you and it's the original recipe
which is such a joy it's so great to be
back with you yesterday Jackson to do it
again I don't know what I did in this
life to be esteemed with such honor
but I wouldn't have it any other way
it's so crazy we used to do this every
day I know and now it's just such a
sweet treat
well I'm happy to be here thank you
everyone yesterday announced my
children's book the camper and the
counselor which you can see here and
also if you're listening as a podcast
check out my Instagram and I got so much
love support I mean how could you not
look at that [__] cover and it just
meant so much so thank you to everyone
who was excited for me and sent their
love and who ordered the book and I
think to to you know thank everyone for
how excited there was so much support to
thank everyone for their support I
should read the second page another page
maybe slowly we'll like end up reading
the whole book okay but you have to
start from the beginning yeah right so I
read the first page yesterday and now
I'm gonna read the second okay
it's the first day of camp my bags are
tightly packed my duffel trunk and
pillow are all neatly stacked we bump
and we bounce up curves bends and Hills
the windy Camp roads give me goosebumps
and chills
we're here I yell as we pull into the
drive we've made it to Camp I'm so glad
to arrive as I head to the bunk I'm
filled with suspense my heart's beating
fast and my shoulders feel tense
now you can get the full book October
10th but pre-order now at
thecamperinthecounselor.com Link in my
bio Link in my stories link everywhere
link up my ass like search me on Amazon
Barnes Noble Target Walmart and yeah
it's the number one children's book on
Amazon right now not it's not a big deal
or anything just you know up there with
your colleagues Dr Seuss and Roald all
rolled out yet yes I woke up today to
the number one children's book spot on
Amazon
is insane and there's so many children's
books out there like there's so many and
it's a really competitive category
you're up there with literally Dr Seuss
what's the one I was saying where do you
go now oh the Places You'll Go the place
is similar literally oh the Places oh
the Places You'll Go like you're up
there like with with the grades with
thus making you a dot dot dot great
question mark exclamation point amen
inevitable
terrible
we'll never stop quoting Vanessa Hudgens
abysmal hysterical
covid Instagram story no I literally
live stream free in my mind the the into
the Amber and the counselor the
intonation and the sort of Rhythm in
which she speaks should be studied it's
so poetic or is it because you've
watched it so many times I haven't even
watched it that many times I've said it
55 000 times maybe it's just me quoting
yours right right it is in my special so
maybe it's me quoting you not Vanessa
that's more me yeah until I quote the
quota no to quote turdy so true and
turdy specials that's my specialty
it's your special turd
anyways make sure to pre-order the book
if you haven't already because it is so
appreciated by me and helpful to me in
terms of like book placement and
bookstores and all that jazz also after
this episode today Claude and I are
recording a patreon episode podcast and
vodcast for the patreon all about the
book we're taking all of your questions
like how I got it published how I found
in illustrator what the process was like
because it was
like a journey 18 month process at this
point yeah
so I'm excited to share all of that it's
going to be fabulous yeah and you know
obviously this is a huge accomplishment
but I kind of accomplished something
like kind of major yesterday too
you got a car I got a car not only did I
get my very first car
I also vlogged the whole thing so that's
also on patreon all the more reason to
become a patreon member like the blog
the episode today like the 300 episodes
that are waiting for you if you join
today
[Music]
literally
yesterday's episode was so fabulous so
funny I was laughing so hard I watched
it again there were so many like funny
things that had me just laughing at upon
remembering that and you know what I
think we should do
we should do it again yeah
what oh my God [__] do that what's
wrong with you don't point at me like
that like I don't know it's just I mean
I would be pointing at me too if you
know if someone was wearing that if I
was you I'd point at me too I'd put at
me too I put at me too yeah I'm wearing
uh era's merch actually got this merch
at a meet and greet uh a few days ago in
Boston such a generous gift I literally
was like grabbing it out of her hands
I'm like no I couldn't accept it I
couldn't she gave me uh era's merch and
she also brought you one and I really
did feel bad taking it but she told me
she works at a radio station and got it
for free so then I didn't feel like wow
she spent her time at the concert
waiting on line no the time and the
money like the energy
I wasn't going to take it until I heard
that she got it for free from work okay
fine yeah no then I was like yeah give a
[__] hand it over I'll allow it I'll
allow it so I'm just like repping my
girls today the camper the counselor and
Taylor
the squad goals Squad goals now we have
a much more relaxed show today yesterday
was like okay I asked me at the book we
had the submersible we had do you still
have this submersible I know we had like
yesterday five really important stories
except for the fifth one
um and today like the stories are chill
chill we're chill we can chill but this
you know the clock has run out you know
the submersible is out of we'll get to
it okay I just like I've thought of
nothing else that's why it's our first
story yeah I feel like everyone's
talking about it they are it's the
craziest saddest thing like ever yeah
and like it's one of those things we'll
really never know unless they unless
they find it right I don't really think
it's like a plane where there's a black
box though like it there's a Logitech
controller you know right it's really
even if it was like a if it was a legit
submarine yeah okay there would be a
black box uh
it's literally a minivan yeah the only
way we would know what would hap what
happened is if they find is if they run
out of oxygen and that was the cause of
death and then they find the submersible
and they're able to see they'll be able
to tell if they find me like how long
those people were in there alive yes but
I don't think they'll find it you don't
think they'll find it I don't well
that's the thing about the sea not to
just be like a stickler for the story
but that's literally our first story and
our most major story okay but that's
just the thing about this I just feel
like you're stepping on the toes of the
house no I'm literally I'm trying to
change topics okay the C is so scary you
know yeah there's so many parts of the
sea that like are Untouched by man like
and they're so dark and like and it just
freaks me out the ocean is so low-key
scary
the dark ocean you know like the Turks
and Caicos ocean is not scary like when
you can't see it
like this yeah you're talking about the
beach
no no like in the Turks of Caicos ocean
like you can go pretty deep and like
it's all clear like you can see that's
not scary there are parts of the ocean
that are like pitch black that are so
deep and like no person has ever gone
before
that's what's scary like I think being
like a maritime
like somebody who works on the ocean
it's like I think I add that to my list
of my like a job I never want to have no
there's definitely Beauty in it for sure
for sure but like there's crazy stores I
think like that's just a job I'm not
built for for sure but like for some
people like to be a fisherman yes
there's the risks but like you're
spending some people sit their whole
life in a cubicle yeah and you get to
look very yeah the job they never want
to have is a cubicle right but I don't
think I could like in uh what's that
book It Happened One Summer yeah how
they're like fishermen and they're in
like the choppy Seattle seas like uh no
yeah no that's a job I'd never want to
have
okay well no one's asking you yeah
that's true you're not qualified
um pretty much I would let Gemma know
that she is a fat [__] and um the shoes
that she gave me were not something I
would particularly buy for myself they
were
old Maiden type of shoes and she said
that those shoes were meant to be worn
on a beautiful woman so if that's the
case she should have put them back on
the rack because she was they
unqualified they would throw you
overboard oh no they were throwing me
overboard I'd better be like I'd get so
like caught up in the beauty at first
I'd be like this is so beautiful we're
so lucky to live in such a great country
the way they would hate you hate you
know those like silent types who like
just live their life on boats oh my God
they would hate hate it yeah and that's
how my story would end
that's why you stay on land that's why I
say I land
so true
so we do have a great show for you today
yes we can talk about nothing other but
the submersible the submersible we could
get into we could is there nothing else
you want to update the crew on like
what's new with you Jack I mean they've
just been like in book in promo mode in
promo mode I finished my other book last
night I've been reading oh I want to
hear how your reading is going
so slow and it has nothing to do with
the book I'm so busy like I have a car
now like I'm so busy maybe you should
listen to the book from your car I'm not
an audiobook girl and I know that
audiobooks tend to take longer than
reading especially for me I'm such a
fast reader and this is a very long book
it says that it's going to take me 10
hours on my Kindle because it's such a
long book I think if I read it it would
take me 25.
I mean if I listen to it it would take
me 25. I don't know I've never listened
to it I don't I'm but I like the book
I'm reading the rose code the rose code
sheet for her book club she asked me for
a recommendation and that's what I
recommended and I do like it it's not my
obviously my type of book but it's good
I'm just I've been so busy and it's
really long I didn't realize how long it
was when I recommended it and I'm not
hating it and if it's good and long
that's fine by me
um I am going away this weekend and I
did just check the weather it's supposed
to rain the entire weekend so I
hopefully you know an upside to that is
that I'll finish the book yeah I mean I
have to finish the book book club meets
next week oh and book club is meeting in
New Jersey because one of our members
lives in New Jersey and I'm driving the
club oh my God in my new car you're
driving everyone well it's like a big
book club and I only have four extra
seats how are you gonna choose I'm just
gonna write like I'm driving come one
come on or the people who listen to the
show will know to ask you for a ride and
that's how you can test your friends
yeah if you're member of the book club
and you're listening and you're
listening here's who I know listens
every day
Margo
and Abe So Not Our Sister Martin not our
sister she would never we have so many
margos in our life Margaret Fish Market
this is about a fish so I know Mark
official listens and I Know Abe listen
so I think they'll probably get the
first two seats now I know Rachel
listens but I don't know if she listens
every day and she's been really busy at
work and she's pregnant so you know I'm
not gonna be mad at a pregnant woman so
I think maybe Rachel will hear it and I
think
I think maybe Michelle will hear it do
you think that Margo or Abe would text
someone no they would let the chips fall
where they may you know they would let
this experiment run uninterrupted Margo
and Abe and Margo and Abe whoever
listens first you could also claim
shotgun yeah
you know Abe's a gentleman he'll let
Marcus in the front
that's nice yeah so it's like kind of
drama at the book club oh wow I know I
should have gotten like a big Suburban
for my car weaponizing your car 100 oh
actually this kind of throws a wrench in
it
Abe I forget what I called him Abe is
actually going to be in New Jersey
before book club starts so I'm only
driving him home so someone gets bummed
no I don't know I don't know what that
means for the for the chauffeur but you
know what the thing about like being the
drivers like I'm doing everyone a favor
like I'm not getting involved yeah like
come as you come on come on how is he
going to get to New Jersey in the first
place maybe he has a car he doesn't
he'll probably Uber I'm not sure
no it's like the the intricacies and the
Dynamics of book club are getting really
complicated
is it gonna be hard for you guys like
while you're in the car on the way there
to not talk about the book yes that's
the thing like in the week leading up to
book club I can't really talk to my
friends who are in book club because
we'll just talk about the book yeah and
then it like spoils all the fun yeah so
also in terms of my car like I got an
Easy Pass
what else do I need like I I almost
forgot the Easy Pass
what you mean for like for life like for
driving like what do you need inside a
car
I got my insurance I got my easy pass
what else do I need
really like do you have an easy bass no
I don't drive on the highway no you
don't drive on the highway and the ones
in Florida are called something
different SunPass that's so much better
like Florida still Florida and it's just
like you literally never even occurred
to me because I will never be on the
highway does Zach's car have an Easy
Pass never seen an easy pass in your car
me neither what do you like pay with
cash on the highway all the time yeah so
I don't know what he does maybe you know
when you run through those things they
just bill it to your house which is not
terrible but he must have one yeah
I've never saw it me neither but I never
looked for Madison incriminating Zach
for avoiding tolls no no I don't think
he avoids tolls
no on ways you can like take it so that
they avoid all the tolls then you like
take four hours to go somewhere that's
like 30 minutes I'll have to ask him
after this one
fact yeah
yes you guys we could oh so anyways I
finished my book that's how we started
uh that Churchill woman it's about
Churchill's mother and I tried to read
it so yeah non-fiction version over the
holidays and it was taking me forever
and I eventually gave up because I was
gonna like not meet my reading goal it
was taking me weeks and I was 20 I think
that's also because the bibliography is
really long I love when they like when
you think the book is long and then
literally with these ones it's like a
forty percent oh that's nice and then
there's like you know
dbqs I love when they put [__] at the
back so it's like unexpected the
bibliography when it's a non-fiction
book oh yeah yeah the bibliography is
half the book please stop saying
bibliography I have like actual Trauma
from school the cited sources that is
worse like so I stopped reading that
book but then I did want to know like
the story of Churchill's mother so I was
like you know what there's a historical
fiction version maybe I haven't
graduated to the level of nonfiction so
I read the historical fiction version
and it was a good like template that
gave me like the outline of her life but
I found it to be really lacking so now I
went back to the book so I'm 20 into
this non-fiction one do you feel like a
sort of kinship to Churchill's mother
since you're both like mothers of Great
Men yes great thinkers historical
figures well definitely being a boy Mom
it's like how do I become the mother of
a great man love that did you give any
tips no she like she's just like really
fabulous
kind of check kind of like made herself
scarce check but who's always there when
when she shot at her when Winnie needed
her win that's what she called it that's
what they call them in the book win win
so I'll let you guys know how my
progress is going going back to
nonfiction but I think I'm gonna like do
a fiction book during the day and then
the non-fiction one at night to help put
me to sleep love that for you yeah and
hopefully between the two I'll get
through it fabulous so that's my reading
update oh and just like another brief
update about maze I've been like
preparing all week for this event I have
tonight uh yeah me and Margaret were
invited to the Summer I Turned Pretty
Premiere uh it's next week I'm literally
I I ordered all these dresses I'm like
panicking I'm like scrubbing my legs to
do spray tan and then I'm thinking I'm
like wait if the event is tomorrow AKA
today this was last night Marco's in
Yellowstone I was like wait is she not
coming with me and then I have to reread
our text where she was like let's go to
this I'm like okay
and it's next week I'm deeply unwell but
it's a Premiere it's a Premiere that's
cool I know I think I'll get to see the
first episode before everyone else are
you gonna walk the red carpet yeah
that's why I got a new dress from one of
my literal favorite Brands like just
shout out Jonathan simkai such gorgeous
things such gorgeous things for a real
woman you know yeah like I feel like I
have so much Jonathan same kind of my
closet like literally size 16 down to
size six and I look good in all of them
like at any size like he really knows
how to flex and yeah oh yeah
the dress that I'm wearing on Thursday
is a size six
I'm so toxic these days and you know
what I live for isn't it awesome it's
awesome to be toxic now I know why
you've been like this your whole life
okay I'm so jealous of you it's okay
like you needed to detox you're going
through a detoxing but you'll be back
don't worry toxic to my core so true to
my core core toxic to my core because
toxicity is like really like genuinely
like a state of mind that was a
descendants reference yeah it was like I
didn't know the song so I didn't jump in
yeah uh for the mamas out there and also
just the people who like descendants and
aren't afraid to share it for our
teenage listeners and for sinach and I
yeah yeah
okay now without further Ado you did say
something I wanted to follow up on what
oh I just wanted to say you got a Sema
okay I'm glad you got that in now
without further Ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know and
today's episode is brought to you by
State Farm the State Farm personal price
plan helps you create a plan that gives
you options so you get an affordable
price and it comes with a lot of
benefits like the coverage you want a
policy that helps cover what's important
to you and an affordable price just for
you and I'm titillated to announce that
today I am an insured woman because
whenever I do these ads I'm like Jackie
has all of her insurance I have
insurance too I have insurance too
because guess what I have a car so I
have insurance and State Farm made it so
easy and that personal price plan is
everything because you want to know
what's so personal insurance and comedy
and food and poetry but most importantly
insurance
State Farm knows how important
personalization is it means you have the
power to choose what you want to include
and what you want to leave out it just
feels better that way and why should
insurance work like that too that's what
the State Farm personal price plan is
all about you can choose to include
options like bundling your home and auto
policies and that means you'll get the
coverage you want at an affordable price
just for you in the end you'll have a
policy that gives you what you want and
doesn't that feel better I'm not at the
stage in my life where I can bundle my
home in Auto because I don't have a home
but like I hope to be there one day
right now I'm an auto girl you know I'm
just an auto girl but maybe I'll be a
home and auto maybe I'll be a Home Auto
and motorcycle you know who knows what
is going to happen to me like a good
neighbor State Farm is there call or go
to statefarm.com today to create your
State Farm personal price plan prices
vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary let me try that one more time
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
today's episode is also brought to you
by JS Health JS Health vitamins are a
science focused vitamin brand and a
wellness brand that provides targeted
formulas to help you meet your personal
health goals created using the highest
quality ingredients backed by research
they're made in Australia and they're
created by expert nutritionist Jessica
sepel JS Health vitamins have a
formulation for you whatever your needs
are from skin digestion stress sleep
hair growth and more Aussies are
globally renowned for their High
supplement standards and it really shows
with these vitamins so the detox and
deep load I think are their best product
they're really popular it's their tried
and true Global bestseller and they're
designed to reduce bloating and support
natural detoxification based on
traditional use which is obviously
traditional evidence is better Jackie we
are so in our detoxification uh you are
you're in your detoxification era the
vegan-friendly formula contains a unique
blend of carefully selected ingredients
including turmeric milk thistle and
fennel at a research backed supplement
dose to support liver function and
promote healthy digestion this is a
Formula that can honestly give you
comfort and confidence very quickly and
if you've experienced bloating you know
a how hard it is to tackle and be like
how uncomfortable and self-conscious it
can make you feel JS health is a really
great brand I love their digestion and
deep bloating
supplements
um check it out if you have like a
bloating issue which I feel like a lot
of us do especially during that time of
the month go to
jshealthvitamins.com toast and use code
toast for 20 off your order or your uh
for subscription order so that's
jshealthvitamins.com toast code toast
for 20 off your order or first
subscription order
thank you Claudia you're welcome so the
latest on the hunt for the Titan
submersible the U.S Coast Guard says
they're not giving up on the hunt for
Titanic five it's still a rescue mission
and they are looking for survivors
despite the oxygen supply running out as
robots trawl the ocean floor and Ocean
Gate co-founder insists that they have
longer than we think
I'm not going with the Ocean Gate
co-founder so there's a bunch of
different theories like which one do you
believe like happened
you know there's one that they're stuck
in the Titanic there's one that like you
know it immediately something went wrong
in oxygen and maybe it imploded
uh not neither I think they are lost and
they lost power and now without oxygen
but maybe they
um
passed away for other reasons it's
really cold down there yeah like there
are things that could have happened in
the last few days
um but now without oxygen like I think
that's it I sincerely hope I don't know
if this is like a bad thing to say that
like they passed away quickly like day
one like because I was watching a tick
tock which of course you know means
nothing but the girl sounded like she
knew what is up like if they are in fact
you know lost without power at the
bottom of the ocean like the conditions
it's freezing down there because of like
the uh the temperature and the sea level
it's probably started um like real like
a lot of condensation inside the vessel
so it's like freezing cold water kind of
pouring not pouring in but like dripping
in there's no seats and it's a round
vessel so they have nowhere to like lean
there's like not really a real bathroom
um there's not a ton of food and there's
limited oxygen and then there's also
just like a bunch of people you don't
know and it's probably pitch black
um if the power went out and down there
it is Pitch Black yeah so um like the
conditions of just being in there are
really like terrible
know what I think happened
I don't think they're stuck inside the
Titanic like that's what people think
they went down there and then maybe like
something like snagged at them right or
like some people say they maybe got
caught on like a fishing net or
something I don't know I don't think
that's it I think like we've we saw how
the thing was built it's so janky
because also it's like if they did get
down to the Titanic why did they lose
contact after an hour and a half right
it's like the machine let them broke
yeah and
I think that's also like the worst case
scenario like the machine broke but
they're still chilling in there yeah
I don't know but if they didn't chart
off course for some reason how come we
can't find
the fast four days if the machine broke
wouldn't they just be like going where
the ocean takes them yeah
but they started that they knew after an
hour and a half that they were missing
like how far could they have gotten and
also I didn't realize they knew after an
hour and it's like weather patterns and
like weight patterns to predict where
something will end up so if they were on
their way down and they lost power then
like you can use
math I didn't figure out where they
would go I didn't realize that they like
it went wrong only an hour and a half in
yeah damn that is so scary like uh I
can't think about it for too long like
because like the
let's say like the theory that they're
like all in there alive like using the
oxygen and like it's too
like more like that's sounds like
horrible like like what nightmares are
made of yeah
and I just can't believe that this thing
has
done the journeys like there are people
coming forward who were on it like this
I guess they had like a bunch of
YouTubers not a bunch like a few
YouTubers over the course of the last
few years come and do it to like promote
Ocean Gate on like if they have like you
know Maritime channels and they have
content that like is very you know
oceany
um and so like all the people who have
done it they're all coming up on my Tick
Tock it's just like I thought this was
like the like the first mission no the
maiden voyage right which was not but it
was the Titanic's maiden voyage it was
yes
and then you were just telling me about
one of the oh right what's so crazy so
Stockton Rush who's the CEO of the Ocean
Gate company who's on the submersible
his wife is a direct descendant of
Isidore and Ida Strauss who were first
class passengers on the Titanic who if
you saw the movie Titanic there's a
couple based on them because they both
stayed on the ship and died together in
the Titanic you see them like in bed
together because
um he wouldn't take a place on a
Lifeboat in place of a woman or a child
and she wouldn't be without him so she
gave her fur coat and her seat to her
maid who lived and was on a Lifeboat and
the two of them died together oh so I
was gonna say how do we know that that
they were like in bed together because
they made I don't know that we don't
know that they were in bed together I
think that's just how like James Cameron
saw got it but that they went down
together with the ship and that they
wouldn't literally gonna cry like it's
so sad and then there that they started
Macy's
Kings yeah oh wait before
before I thought you were saying like
the maid went on to start Macy's I'm
like oh my God I love that for her no
the strauss's got it that's such a sad
sweet story yeah sad sweet story and
like direct descendant of them like
daughters son Sons daughter it was Wendy
Rush no um
Titanic is cursed okay but let me ask
you like a really weird question like do
you think it's just a coincidence that
this guy's obsessed with the Titanic and
he married oh no I don't think it's a
coincidence that's an amazing question
like maybe on their first date like he
found that out about her and like maybe
he sought her out he's so wealthy he was
like find me the most beautiful woman
who's currently a descendant of someone
on the Titanic yeah no I don't think
it's a coincidence I think they were on
their first date and like he's
definitely like a history and he's
obviously like Maritime cares about the
Titanic and that probably was the thing
that like was like oh my God no by the
way that's literally the craziest thing
I've ever heard I didn't even think
about it but you're 100 right he's
obsessed he's obsessed
oh my God the story gives me such a pit
like I guess tomorrow was wrong
if there was ever a time for her to be
right like this would be it this would
have should have been it would have
could have should have
um I like him so pitsville obsessed like
I can't stop consuming I refresh the
Daily Mail
from Paige every like time I remember
because I'm like is there an update oh
another theory which is honestly just as
scary is that like they popped back up
on the surface somewhere but this thing
is bolted from the outside it's 17 bolts
that can only be open from the outside
so maybe they did resurface like a
couple miles down the shore and they're
chilling up above the water but they
can't even get out so if they don't find
them and they run out of oxygen but now
that they're up above the water do they
still need all that oxygen yes it's it's
completely sealed oh another theory is
that they have like hell they are trying
but another theory is that um there was
just a leak
like a hole Yeah a hole and it like
flooded and and sunk and that's
obviously a terrible way to go to but I
think in the list of you know all the
possibilities here it's not the worst
one
so nobody knows you know every expert is
on every News Channel and they're all
saying different things but also like if
it was what you said you know
they're there for four days
they could cut the oxygen like maybe
they know they're not getting found I
mean but you know would you give up that
hope like immediately and like kill
everyone and by the way immediately but
in the more peaceful way for sure or but
they're like but what if they find us
tomorrow you know yeah and then that's
where like human nature comes in because
it's five people they all have to agree
yeah and you know a guy is sitting there
with his son so he's not gonna be like
yeah let's all kill ourselves he's a 19
year old son he's gonna be like no we
need to give a fighting chance for him I
said okay well if he's watching his son
suffer I don't know I don't know we'll
never know what went on we'll never know
what went on inside and like that it
will haunt me yeah well if they find it
we'll have some answers
cause of death
which would let us know
time day yeah
it's so terrible I've seen a lot of
people being like really
um like rude about this there's a lot of
jokes going around no and like you know
what I can I don't mind the jokes like
it's like whatever but like some people
are just being like really dismissive
and rude because like these are all
billionaires and it's like okay like
I'm jealous too but like they shouldn't
die no it's really sad it is really sad
and the stepson just keeps making news
he does people like tweeting out only
fans he said he's tweeting at cardi B
he's tweeting at Travis saying like hey
I would love to come backstage um the
stepson make you feel better yeah no
he's clearly like a little
um like socially off yeah so I think we
need to give him like a little bit of
Grace but he also uh somebody needs to
take his phone away like his stepmother
perhaps like somebody needs took the
phone away yeah I saw um he was making
some Instagram stories he responded to
cardi B Because cardi B was like talking
about this thing she's like it's so
crazy did anybody see the stepson go to
the Blink 182 concert she's like go home
like your family needs you and
he was like I knew you were a bad
musician but I didn't know you were
classless like he's like fighting with
her it's so weird this is just like it's
giving like this is not real you know
yeah
no it's not but
um we'll keep you posted hopefully we
get some news any news over the weekend
and we'll know more on Monday perhaps
are you ready for our next story I am
shifting gears in a major way shifting
streisands in a major way since I miss
that angel I know he's so sweet gotta
bring to the studio it's been a while
yeah he would love to be here yeah
getting his ass up here sitting with his
arm around me here oh my angel's dry
sand Kendall Jenner says she's always
felt out of place in her family quote I
didn't choose this life
Kendall didn't choose a life of Fame she
was born into it the family supermodel
explained how she's made peace with life
in the spotlight alongside her famous
family so she is on the cover of wsj
magazine summer digital issue a lot of
photos really beautiful photos yeah she
said since I was really young I felt out
of place in my family I was born into
this life but I didn't choose this life
she added I'm not Built For This by any
means I'm not good at it I do it and
I've learned how to do it
so I I think a lot of people are like
taking these quotes and being like pick
me energy
um and I think there might have been a
time where like I didn't really
understand Kendall and I would have
rolled my eyes at this too but like I
kind of do understand what she's saying
and I think there's like a there's a
history especially on the show of her
like really not dealing well at all with
what she does for a living
um so I don't like have sympathy for her
because like she's very blessed but I
get what she's saying and she's not
built for this like the way that like
you know scandals happen and like Kim
and Chris like they belly up like they
were made for this Kendall is not like
Kendall is like
she's just not yeah I most people aren't
I agree I feel like I was watching the
show last week and I feel like she did
she doesn't even model as much anymore
like she has 818 and I think she just
like tries to hang out with her friends
and ride her horses and like she does
like a few like big campaigns but she's
not doing every show like not like she
used to so I'm sure she's found like a
balance yes that works for her
and agreed it's not like you know
we're all gonna be crying tears that
Kendall didn't choose it's like she's
allowed to talk about her life so true
and how she feels about it no and I
actually think 818 was probably one of
the better better things that ever like
happened to her because it's extremely
successful like it's everywhere I think
it's valued like super super like I
think it it could be one of the things
that makes her the next billionaire
um
and I think it's uh it's allowed her the
luxury to turn down a bunch of things
and do like one long sham thing a year
yeah and then go ride her horses it's a
better work-life balance yeah and I
think a model is hard in its own way
aside from like you know the constant
working and traveling and this and that
like it's you know tough on your body
yeah your mental health yeah
um not us feeling bad for models
um also you've modeled a few times and
it's hard no by the way I have immense
respect for models it's literally the
worst job like fisherman or model model
um like especially if you're like a
deeply self-conscious person which I
think even models are
um you have no control over like how
they dress you and how they do your
makeup and it's like you're comfortable
in like what you know and they want to
put you in like this ping get up and
you're like no please give me black like
it's really like any time I've ever like
been on a set for like like I've been on
a set like making you know doing photos
like for our headshots like that I mean
because you're in control for another
brand like hell on Earth I literally
hated every minute of it it's really bad
it's horrible and it's like your time is
not your own yeah your body is not your
own your face it's not your own your
hair is not your own like it's really
like not fun models are people too no
it's so true like not me sitting here
like feeling bad for models and Kendall
Jenner I'm a truly a changed woman you
are because this is so something I would
have rolled my eyes out ah rolled my
eyes at
yeah
um and I think a lot of the girls back
to 818 are investors in 818 the sisters
yeah so I think this will be really good
for all of them remember they had that
like investors meeting and they were all
there
oh it wasn't like an investors meeting
what I mean maybe it was but like if you
had an investors meeting for
I don't know turdy Lou Global I would be
there because I'm your sister well [__]
you better be an investor no but by the
way no I'm sorry I'm pretty sure it's
like a fact like they all invested
but you're not talking about that dinner
I think the fact that they were at a
dinner for her I'm not talking about the
one on the show oh okay no no I knew you
okay like like a year ago there were all
those Paparazzi pictures it was like the
eight and they like rented a house and
they had like a big board meeting that
was on the show that was the one from
the show The Outfits were the same oh
yeah they're all investors like it's
like it's known maybe not every single
maybe not like Courtney but aside from
that dinner though like take the dinner
out yes it's a fact otherwise very cool
yeah and I think that's something they
recently started doing I think at first
when they were starting businesses like
I don't think anybody invested in Kylie
Cosmetics big mistake huge she didn't
need investors right
um
and I don't know if anybody invested in
skims yes everyone is invested in skin
the girls oh this is oh sorry I thought
you just meant investors no I'm talking
about the family like I know they used
to go out and get investors for things
yeah but now like they can be their own
investors and I think a lot of them
invested in 818 I think maybe that was
like their first foray into that which
is smart maybe now they're all investors
in Lemmy that's interesting
I'm gonna need more proof okay I'm not
I'm not convinced but I think it would
be really nice yeah no it's smart yeah
you want to invest in Cambrian counselor
sure can I get a steak it's the number
one children's book is it not too late I
guess it is too late because now we're
successful so like yeah it's so easy to
get on board yeah when you're the number
one children do you want to take a
chance on an unknown children by the way
I 100 by the way I would have 100 if you
needed money which you didn't and second
of all uh
who has been a bigger Champion since day
one of the camper the counselor honestly
I should get equity for how much like
positive energy I've put out there for
you it's so true I'm obsessed we'll talk
about it on the patreon okay because
people are like oh my God is Margo like
just so
um excited I wrote a book about her I'm
like she's a snitch she's like oh cool
she's like oh just another thing like
made in in my image so awesome thanks
yeah cool send me a copy
[Laughter]
he's too cool for her own good that's
natural I know but that's why she is
that's why she is the counselor written
about her so true it's just kind of like
Daisy Jones like yeah
it's just like wild child yeah
are you ready for our next story which
is something that Claudia and I have
been talking about and we have questions
oh I have so many questions so Jennifer
Lawrence poses on the red carpet for her
new movie no hard feelings she brought
her parents to the event and that's
really cute she looked amazing in a
one-shoulder Dior she's looking like
incredible she took like a major chunk
of time off she had a baby obviously and
she just came back looking snatched to
the [__] God it's like that
perfect face yeah she looks amazing she
is amazing but what is this movie yeah
okay so I remember I literally remember
where I was when I first saw a poster
for this movie and I was so confused I
was in an Uber we were heading down to
the South Street Seaboard to have lunch
with Harry and you remember me and
member in this Uber we pull and like you
know those Billboards that are like on
construction sites yeah it was like get
a free car if you go out with my son and
it looked like a Craigslist ad because
that's like the premise of the movie and
I'm like is that Jennifer Lawrence like
is this prank I'm like is this a movie
it took 15 minutes for me to realize
it's a movie and now there was a
premiere last night and there's been
like all these commercials and she's on
buses and stuff and I'm so confused like
what is this movie
um it's like obviously like a rom-com
it's getting like early Miles Teller
energy it's giving like Failure to
Launch like kind of like She's Out of My
League movie kind of I encountered this
movie because a few weeks ago I saw a
trailer for it and I'm like am I in a
time machine no I was so it's literally
it's the most confusing and then the
time machine where Jennifer Lawrence is
doing like slapstick comedy movies that
don't even get made anymore Project X
Vibes yeah movies that like were popular
15 years ago and she looks 15 years
younger like she looks so young these
days I'm like am I in a time am I a time
traveler so
she's clear she's like an academy
award-winning actress everything she
does is like she doesn't do anything bad
and there's a few like what I know
mother okay even though it wasn't for us
like it's beyond critically acclaimed
really yeah it's like it's considered a
great film and I don't get it but yeah
so this is like a deeply selective
person she has the luxury to do that I
have to imagine this movie's incredible
like I know it sounds so crazy but
that's the only way that this would make
sense I have heard it premiered last
night I've actually heard it's
hysterical
I don't know if that's just from like
people being paid to say that I don't
know
I'm so confused and the only way this
would make sense if this is if this ends
up being the most hilarious movie
and the thing is but even if it's the
funniest movie
why I don't know like how do you go from
Silver Linings to this and American
Hustle yeah
she's just clearly like she's the type
of gal who does one movie a year it's
the biggest movie of the year it wins
all the Oscars and she gets nominated
every year Joy
Joy I [__] love joy I don't know I
I just I need answers I have like maybe
a few theories one like the paycheck was
of course too much but like how for a
ROM like how would they have all this
money
to get Jennifer Lawrence to do a movie
that she wouldn't want to do maybe like
I don't know something in her personal
life she's just like I'm kind of tired
of these stories like I Just Want to
Have Fun possible that's very possible
maybe she's bringing the rom-com back
which I'm so here for It's So Random no
I'm so confused like I need it explained
to me by like a Hollywood studio exact
like come on the podcast and explain it
I don't get it Jennifer herself like
where she was at when she said yes to
this and also you have to see the movie
now because yeah yeah no I I plan to and
I love Jayla love so I just I needed to
make sense I hate when things don't make
sense I'm a sensible girl extremely so I
have questions
and hopefully this film holds the answer
maybe it's like the best movie of all
time
like that's the only way this would
truly make sense
maybe or like who's the director maybe
it's a friend yeah maybe you're saying
maybe this was a favor yeah we're like
oh my God you my friend who I love and I
love their work is doing like this cool
project they want me to be in it like
maybe cook got her involved you know but
he's so artsy yeah this is so awesome so
non-cook approved for sure yeah
maybe she's rebelling against the last
few years that have been like so artsy
right like you think I'm so perfect and
artsy
I'll show you commercial we just I'm
spiraling like I need I need a concrete
answer as to what's going on here if
anyone's seen the movie I don't even
know if it's out yet but like drop a
comment how is it agreed but you're
gonna go see it I will I will okay great
speaking of movies our next story is it
the movie that speaking of the next
story is brought to you by Lululemon yep
fabulous Lululemon shorts were made to
stretch flex and support the infinite
ways of working out giving you the
courage to lead into something totally
new and unexpected so Lululemon is known
for everything you know it's the place
to go especially in the summertime for
their shorts so uh we love the hottie
hot short it's a short with a
comfortable range of motion and a
flattering fit they allow you to Max
your stride so you can move freely with
confidence the lightweight Swift fabric
lets in airflow so you can move without
baggage it's designed to Wick away sweat
before you even notice that it's there
carry your Essentials with two perfectly
placed and very discreetly placed
pockets as well they also have the
Wonder train short which is a fabulous
short it's the shore with supportive
stretch that also keeps you dry it's
powered by everlux fabric the Wonder
train collection manages heat and sweat
so that you stay comfortable and focused
so the material is sweat wicking quick
drying it's very breathable it's perfect
for this time of year you know our
nether regions are getting moist we've
got crevices and creases of Plenty and
we've got to keep them safe during this
time of year and Lululemon knows that
they're also keeping the undercarriage
of your man safe as well because the
pace breaker short are their
best-selling men's short it's a
versatile short that's up to any
challenge the fabric is super ult super
lightweight so you can train move and
stretch how you want Secure Storage
means that you can keep things close
without feeling them bounce around each
pair of pace breaker short is designed
to Wick away moisture so all that's left
behind is your intention get into the
Lululemon shorts at lululemon.com that's
l u l u l e m o n.com Lululemon is a
trusted a trusted friend especially
during the summer time today's episode
is also brought to you by Game Time find
tickets for your favorite events should
not be stressful yet here we are game
time is the fast and easy way to buy
tickets for all the sports music comedy
and theater near you with killer deals
on last minute tickets and their best
price guarantee you can stop stressing
over tickets and start getting hyped for
the fun you're gonna have game time is
the place for last minute ticket deals
so forget planning months in advance
that's so me like if something's going
on tonight I'll buy a ticket tonight you
know game time has deals on tickets
right up to the day of the event get
exclusive Flash Deals on tickets for
football basketball baseball concerts
comedy theater and more if you're
traveling it's so great to have the game
time app just download it on your phone
because it's you know oh I'm in
Charlotte for the night what's going
down maybe I can go to a Bobcats game
you know things like that the game time
guarantee also means that you'll get the
best price out there if you find tickets
for the same section and row for Less
game time will credit you 110 of the
difference it's the fastest growing
ticket app in the country for reasons
you're getting images of your seats
before you buy you can buy in a matter
of seconds and the tickets are sent
directly to your phone so you never have
to dig through your email
snag the tickets without the stress with
Game Time download the game time app
create an account and use code toast for
20 off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account and redeem code
toast t-o-a-s-t for twenty dollars off
download Game Time download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed they had a bunch of good
seats also on game time for the Aeros
tour which I was really surprised for
because those tickets were really hard
to find but whether you know you're in a
new town you live in a fabulous town you
want to go see Jerry Seinfeld at the
Beacon whatever it is I've used game
time for a lot of stuff specifically
Nick games Ben loves it because they
have really good pricing
um game time it's the app for tickets
game time
yeah and when Claudia sings the national
anthem somewhere you'll get your tickets
on game oh brief update I have been
offered um not one but two opportunities
I I need to make my call out a little
more specific yeah I need you to sing in
New York yeah in the tri-state area
because I'm going yeah and I can't go to
Oakland so I saw an email from both the
Oakland days and the Orlando Magic and
I'm so grateful but Jackie needs to be
there so or you could do Orlando Magic
what sport is that basketball oh like in
the fall sure I mean basketball's not
even in season right now so I think that
would that would actually be great for
me yeah but like I'm a New Yorker and so
I think if I'm gonna do it anywhere like
I have to do it here but like you could
do it more than once so book Orlando
Magic for the fall we'll go maybe I do
like a tour
but you we need turdy singing the
National Anthem this summer in New York
where I just want to say yeah like I
just want to say like I really don't
want to do it like like honestly it's
not for you it's for the country and
it's for me when I got that email from
the Oakland days which I was so
flattered about like I kind of got a pit
like like
I don't like I'm just scared like you
know what I mean you're gonna be amazing
and you're gonna practice Yeah I need to
like I need I need a few weeks so I can
get get on with my um
vocal coach or if someone drops out last
minute she'll be there yeah in New York
in New York the land of the free
and the home
and it looks so ugly when I sing I'm
gonna have to work on my face
don't worry about that okay
are there any sports in season right now
other than baseball
you got the wrong girl I don't know so
true football's coming back in the fall
but football oh my God sorry I want
turkey
I wanted to be baseball so that you can
throw the first pitch and we can do like
a Duo thing no I know but I'm not gonna
ask like I'm not gonna get crazy like I
just need you singing the National
Anthem
I listen I would do it in a heartbeat
but like I also know you know we can't
get everything on our ask list yeah
that's true so I need you singing the
National Anthem in New York this summer
where I can go okay
okay I'm putting that out there okay it
really shouldn't be so hard you guys
heard her yesterday she sounded it
really shouldn't be so hard I did
perform at Madison Square Garden like
I'm kind of like an MSG artist no but
this is you working on your singing
career now yeah like you kind of are
starting from the ground floor like I
mean you know what I've done it once
I'll do it again I started as a comedian
you know just trying to be taken
seriously now here I am
next up
the Grand Ole Opry
next up another movie news Priscilla
trailer drops Sophia Coppola this is so
weird Tells A different kind of Elvis
biopic starring Jacob elordi and Kaylee
spani so the trailer dropped and the new
pictures honestly they're gorgeous
[Music]
it looks good I mean Jacob elordi is a
great selection for Elvis Sophia Coppola
is a queen like
I'm sure it'll be a great film but like
what is with this timing like it's just
it's so Random after like all the Elvis
Fanfare for literally two years I know
but that's just how things go when it
rains it pours yeah plus between that
and like then Riley Keough coming up and
yeah Lisa Marie passing away like it's
just been a lot of Elvis news yeah
personally like I wasn't a not not a fan
but I just didn't participate
until I saw the movie and it made a fan
out of me so I feel like whatever
they're doing is really and this film is
obviously like more centered on
Priscilla's story yeah which Priscilla
was kind of like silenced in the regular
Elvis one yeah she wasn't about her
Elvis Who's playing
um Kaylee spani who I don't know but she
looks gorgeous and I read Priscilla's
book and so I don't think she has a
story to tell oh for sure how can you be
married to the king so Priscilla is
Riley's grandmother who she just sued
yes got it I don't think they'll cover
that in the movie but no it's clearly it
said it's set when Elvis was alive
correct or does it span you know like
their wedding cute yeah and it's oh it's
based on her Memoir that I read great
and will it be in theaters is that is it
that type of movie yeah it's Sophia
Coppola or like it's not like a Netflix
uh it doesn't say that it's going
anywhere specific all right I guess I
gotta head to the theaters
yes the Jennifer Lawrence movie called
again no hard feelings so weird
so all right maybe I'll do a double
feature back to back a rainy Sunday you
know I once did that it was like my
dream to see two movies I think I was
there at the movies Molly's game Molly's
game and then greatest showman yeah but
it wasn't my first time seeing greatest
showman and
I found it to be really difficult I
couldn't process the first movie right
like I just seen Molly's game which is
like an amazing movie and now I have to
take in greatest showman you need like a
lunch break schedule do you need like 11
A.M movie It's Like A Rainy Sunday you
wake up you go to the movies at 11 A.M
11 to 1 you watch the first movie one to
two you have lunch 2 15. I don't even
know if it's enough time to process like
especially it depends on what movie
you're seeing yeah but like for me Molly
seemed like there was so much to think
about Molly's game was a real you know
provocative film so like I'm sitting oh
man I'm thinking about Molly's game
I was I was overwhelmed we light it up
we won't come down and the sun can't
stop us now watching it come through
it's taking over you oh I haven't seen
the greatest showman in a while it's so
good it really is I think I watched it
like so many times in the first like two
years that it came out that kind of got
sick of it now I think enough time has
passed we're like I really need to see
it again and you know who needs to see
it like now Kayla needs to get in turn
ready to show Monera Kayla's in her high
school musical era courtesy of Auntie I
knew she would love it and she's
obsessed she says that she is Gabriella
Mama Sharpay and dad is Ryan
she's so funny really funny no she's
obsessed like I was watching I was like
the last time I went down to Florida I
had just been watching High School
Musical and I loved that final scene of
the third film it's so beautiful and
it's so well done and I was thinking I
was like Caleb would love this final
scene like it's so colorful there's
dancing there's singing it's outside so
I put on the final scene and the way she
was obsessed I left the next day Olivia
was like she keeps screaming High School
Musical High School Musical now they've
watched everybody watch every film like
every night one two and three she's
obsessed she loves one too yeah but
there's nothing quite like that final
scene I want the rest of each build up
like one is so good yeah okay two is a
little weird but it's still like
better than one in terms of like
production they had more money they had
like you know we're traveling Country
Club and then three is just like an
amalgamation and all cylinders and it
had like big movie
budget and it had heart I don't feel
like too had heart I completely or one
had heart two they were like really
trying to come between Trey and
Gabriella which like who needs that
three is like literally you could cry
yeah like at the end I want the it
captures that it just that like
nostalgic adolescence like you know your
whole life is in front of you but you're
like so sad that it's ending it's really
it's kind of like the camper and the
counselor it is but it's also like that
quote you know there's no one older than
a high school senior or younger than a
college freshman exactly
I love that I never heard that really
yeah it hits the nail on the head yeah
because you think you know everything
when you graduate high school and then
you go to college and you're like I'm So
Young when you uh young they assume you
know nothing
because you don't
know anything it's so true and is that
scary because like I think if you think
you know everything now no like 10 years
ago I was like no one can tell me
[__] [__] [__] like I run this town
um I was literally like an ogre writing
this down like I was a big dumb poker
riding the swamp literally I was this
big dumb idiot loser knew nothing but
you couldn't tell me [__] [__] like I
knew [__] everything now I'm like oh
wow I really knew nothing back then but
now I know everything in 10 years I'm
gonna be like you're a [__] [__] no
I think it starts the curve of like you
know extreme learning it does start to
like Plateau but like so you're not
gonna have that exact same feeling 10
years from now as you do about you today
like you are more similar than you you
today and you in 10 years are more
similar than me and me 10 years ago yeah
yeah enough facts
are you
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yeah I just love when you get to
that stage in pregnancy we're like you
can't really laugh so hard yeah and it
makes like every little giggle you you
giggle so much more exaggerated and it's
like I didn't say anything that funny
but like you were laughing so hard
because you're like pregnant and just it
makes me funnier I don't know that I was
laughing like so hard no but like you
were for like for like how dumb of a
joke I made like fax you and you're like
you really laughed I did laugh
that we can agree on this magnitude it's
so toxic oh my God
that was one this is a toxic workplace
for sure for sure I wouldn't have it any
other way me neither are you ready for
our fifth and final story yes
Elon Musk picks Vegas as a destination
for his cage match challenge with Mark
Zuckerberg I can't really I can't get
involved in like more honesty like this
I'm obsessed is morons fight fight
you're never gonna pull up you're gonna
you're like that kid in high school who
has like braces
[Laughter]
and you have like your phone out and
you're like you weigh like 60 pounds and
you're gonna be like five five
Twitter owner and Tesla CEO Elon Musk
suggested Las Vegas for the location of
a cage match after reportedly being
challenged to a fight by Facebook
co-founder Mark Zuckerberg it's like two
of the world's like biggest losers like
the like the way that they look like
come on no but I feel like where thirdly
they would both be in shape for some
sort of fight like I think Mark
Zuckerberg probably does like Jiu Jitsu
yeah Elon Musk probably does Krav Maga
they both like they literally have this
like they're paler than ghosts like they
have this skin of like a young Victorian
child they look so weak uh watching
these two fight it's honestly I know
it's taking place in Vegas it really
should take place in loserville like
well Elon tweeted Vegas octagon late
Wednesday he was responding to an
Instagram post by Mark Zuckerberg who
had shot back with a message of send me
location after the Tesla boss confirmed
he was up for a cage match
in Vegas no I mean if we if if these two
are fighting like my money is 100 on
Elon
just because of like the way that they
look build build Elon is a little bit
bigger the other one is so slim and I'm
like Mark Zuckerberg is like it's just a
big time weenie like yeah Mark
Zuckerberg has never had an original
thought in his life like everything Mark
Zuckerberg has ever accomplished has
been stolen from someone else like he
just doesn't give me like fighter Vibes
no he doesn't give me fighter and I know
your brain has like nothing to do with
like how well you would fight but like I
think I would trust elon's like full
full thing more than
Denmark yeah but like it reminds me of
um Love and Death where it's like what's
her name Betty and and Candy the candy
was smaller but in her in her brain like
she was a fighter yep yep yep yep no I
completely agree like
yeah my money's on Elon my money's on
Elon I'm sure Vegas's biggest has odds
on how long and if and when they're
gonna find the submersible so they
definitely have the odds already said oh
I saw I got an email with some odds yeah
um
I didn't know what it meant though like
people are placing bags no no I didn't
okay this is I'll show you what I got
okay I don't know oh it went to our
morning toe show email so you got it too
the fight winner odds Elon Musk so now
they have odds for oh okay okay minus
150 for we say that again
minus 150. and Mark Zuckerberg Plus 110.
that means they think Mark Zuckerberg's
gonna win no that means musk is a slight
favor oh
I never understand like I don't know how
that works
like I figured if you have the plus like
you're you're positive Sports things
it's Aladin it's not looking nice right
it's going well
if it did it would be iconic it's too
bad that neither of these men need the
money because like I'm sure pay-per-view
would like literally pay them each 100
million dollars to do it of course yeah
like they pay Logan Paul that so they'd
pay Elon Musk but these are two people
who quite literally can't be bought no
but maybe for like a donation charity I
wonder what what moves them
yeah that's a good question
like they're not motivated by money
anymore they're not motivated by like
social status
the things that matter to most people
like has Mark Zuckerberg ever been to
the Met Gala I believe so yes hmm we
could give them free tickets I feel like
charity
but they could also like donate if
they're so moved like they have the
money to do this charity
I don't know what do you think it's
gonna take I don't know I don't think it
will happen but my money's on Elon and
it's funny and it's funny like that
they're beefing yeah billionaires
billionaire things can't live with them
can't live without them
all right that's our show tis it's our
final in studio episode for the week
tomorrow is a remote Audio Only podcast
thanks for lugging your ass in here two
days in a row I know it's not easy
um like yesterday was for you and today
was for me so yeah yeah no I don't want
to do two remote episodes like I try to
avoid remote as much as possible yeah
but tomorrow's remote it's Friday like
it's summer
summer summer summer summer
that's our show thank you so much for
listening to the toast in London Morning
Show where we deliver the fast five
stories from Monday through Friday on
YouTube so you're watching us on YouTube
please don't forget to subscribe give a
student a thumbs up Spotify
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing Thursday and we'll see you
tomorrow for Friday Friday get your copy
of the counselor in camper yes at the
camper and the counselor.com
also available on Amazon
and Target and Walmart
bye